and we are set to go with your
right-hander riley smith gets the start
for the d-backs tonight seven
appearances this year four starts as bob
mentioned he cut to grom over the
weekend and now he gets max sure
shortstop trey turner will lead it off
oh oh it'll be his home run ball he
gives up c
u
later and trey turner has done it again
adding to his nationals record his 14th
leadoff home run
trey turner one of the best in the
business
did not waste any time in the desert to
get us on the board trey turner was one
of the best short stops in all the
baseball great short compact swing and
that was a no doubter off the bat yeah
well one thing about hitting with the
base is loaded you as a hitter have to
realize that you have all the advantage
there the pressure is on the pitcher in
this situation
[Applause]
tried to jam him and that's down the
right field line
soto will score schwarber will score
castro heading for third
josh bell has come alive maybe yesterday
got him going and now he's in a ballpark
he knows so well well josh bell loves
hitting in the desert
what a great swing right here 02 got
beat by this slider a little bit but
he's strong he's able to keep it fair
and score two
goms is hitting seven of his last nine
he's at 243. two doubles four homers and
eleven runs batted in
now the old one swung on and belted to
the gap and left center field that gets
down and will roll all the way to the
wall and clear the bases castro trots in
from third bell around third he comes in
to score combs standing at second with
his third double of the year rbis 12 and
13. and it's a big big first inning for
the nationals in phoenix it's now
washington 5 in arizona nothing
as he backs with two out in a runner at
third and five runs in
the kick of the pitch breaking ball
hitting the air to left field this is
way back there and will fall in along
the line fielded on a hop by peralta the
left fielder and in the score from third
is gomes
and robles in the second
with a double for victor his third
double his second run bannon of the year
nine nationals have batted in the inning
it's now washington six in arizona
nothing bottom of the first hitting the
nationals with six runs on the board
before max scherzer ever throws a pitch
he makes his eighth start of the year
two and two record 2.33 era
and pavon smith left-handed hitting
right fielder leads off
nasty down and in
cutting action on the 90 and max here's
your 62nd strike out of the year in 46
and two short centers
max's sliders have two different kind of
breaks on them one goes laterally that
one drop state straight down
and schwarber waits for this one and
hits it well to left center c
u
later
second and opposite field homer in two
days he is feeling good he's schwarber
and bell
here they come we've been waiting for
this man and i told you it was only a
matter of time
only a matter of time
almost deja vu from yesterday's home run
at nats park ty
stayed on this changeup out over the
middle of the plate and he knew as soon
as he hit it that it was gone look at
this thing absolutely scorched and riley
smith is in disbelief
he's like where did everything go wrong
today
you have to pay attention that you're
not facing caleb smith you've got to
know it's riley smith
the one two swinging a fly ball to
center this is deep heading back on it
the center fielder of our show looking
up now and this one plays off the wall
gomes motoring for second rounding
second trouble picking the ball up for
varsho and gomez is gonna dig for third
and he's gonna slide in with a triple
so the nationals catchers are piling up
the triples alex avila had one the other
night and here a triple leading off the
third inning for gomes as varshall
turned played the caramel off the high
25 foot wall about midway up
hit off the top of the padding halfway
up the wall
blaze jacks one to right center that's
gonna plug the gap another triple he's
thinking three until they stop it john
gomez coming in
and the gnats are slugging in the big
airplane hangar tonight robles now with
three rbis on the year
well i thought for a second he was going
to go three
absolute scorcher into the opposite
field gap
great job by robles max scherzer first
two winnings 36 pitches
21
strikes change up right down the middle
but he threw the hitter's timing off and
that's what the off speed is all about
and that's why max is so tough i mean
any pitch any count
stuff is pretty much unhittable and mac
surgery even though he threw a ball
right over the heart of the plate had
the hitters timing so upset and out of
sync there he got the strikeout now he
gets the pitcher looking two down let's
see what he has on o2
oh nothing off speed in on the hands
strikeout number five
yeah just as i said
you know if a guy gets touched up on
their all speed they're they're going to
go back to the theater
3-2
boom
strikeout number six
nothing fancy here it is i've got an
eight-run lead see what you can do
driven in 12 scoring 23 times
that is guaranteed when trey plays the
d-backs
turner the other way
that's fair into the corner
bell home
gomes home
the nets are in double digits in the top
of the fifth inning and trey turner has
a homer and a double himself with three
batted in
and we are an extra base machine as a
club tonight good two-strike approach
you see he got his stride foot down
early on this change up out over the
plate able to sneak it inside the right
field fair line
[Applause]
pitch up
there's some turf there we go josh
harrison
it's 11 to nothing
stevenson holm turner to third
and everybody having a big time tonight
yeah he definitely deserved that one
after his last three at bats
he squared up the ball in every single
at bat so far
great job here on this elevated change
up
washington conceding the run here and
the ground ball will score the run
harris and has got it in the outfield
grass
throws to first pavement smith scores
the fans tear the dimebacks are on the
board it's 11-1 no shun out here b.c
j maxx dk at nationals park
and a bouncer up the middle that'll back
up the second baseman
bell easily beats it out and josh bell
has his third rbi of the night
[Applause]
that's a clean base hit see bob all you
gotta do is talk about it racing home is
stevenson and juan soto is part of the
hit parade welcome to the party juan and
then
shuffle yeah now the nets have a baker's
dozen
and schwarber hits one hard that's a
tweener
runners all over the place yadiel
hernandez comes home to score
soto to third
and it's 14-1 and kyle schwarber has a
three-hit knight on base
five
times we tend to look elsewhere for
bullpen help and toy lavello looked down
to left field so here is
the freight train david peralta on the
mound to start tonight
he waits for that one and jacks it to
right
c
u
later that is halfway up the bleachers
bomb
andrew stevenson
that's going to bring in three and make
it 17
to one
440 feet
[Applause]
the smasher smashes one deep to center
andrew young
what a catch by stevenson and he dropped
it
peralta will come in with run number two
andrew young deep to center
oh he jammed him and at 12 54 am
washington time
this three hour and 14 minute game
will be over with the gnats winning it
in large fashion